and we've got Grandmaster Maurice Ashley
he's with a kitty ratcliffe and they're
going to talk about some of the great
things that's happening with st. Louis
and chess yes with the president of
explore st. Louis kitty ratcliffe
welcome back to our show thank you nice
to be back so what's new going on and
say Louis these days I know there's
always something happening in this great
city tell us what what new things have
propped up you mean in addition to the
sink felt Cup going on right now you
know is that some tournament they say
showing tournament worldwide exposure
well we have a 380 million dollar
project going on right now down on the
arch ground so gateway arch which is an
iconic structure for us worldwide
recognition is getting a remake and redo
and that project will be done in about a
year so 300 watching phases she even 80
million and most of that is local money
there there was a little bit of federal
money put into it government money for
rerouting some roads but everything else
is pretty much raised locally what are
they gonna do is they give it a dress a
new museum new museum highly interactive
the the original museum was built in the
60s and so some of those exhibits were
very 1960s and now they're going to be
very modern and interactive for for
young people to come in and explore the
Gateway to the West and the whole reason
that the Jefferson National expansion
was done in the first place and so it's
good thing a lot of other good things
yeah a lot of other good things
happening we have a lot of work that's
being done at union station right now an
incredible laser light show that plays
every single night multiple times a
night so people can go in and experience
that and they've got a big announcement
coming up next week about some
additional things they're going to do so
is it free it is actually yeah it is it
sounds like my fantastic let's see you
know it's the original translation the
old train station which it isn't a train
station anymore it's a hotel but the
lobby has this huge barrel vaulted
ceiling with all it's all stained glass
and so what they've done is they've gone
and put LED points throughout the
ceiling and and then they run these
combined LED and laser shows each one is
different so you could go and you could
spend an evening in the which is also a
bar you can spend an evening in their
lobby bar having cocktails and watch a
different show every hour and they're
absolutely amazing and it is free except
unless of course you want to buy a
cocktail it sounds wonderful yes now
tell us about the same field cup of
being here and all the great chess
events that come to st. Louis what does
that mean for an organization like yours
well you know we have about 22 23
million visitors who come to st. Louis
every year and it's a it's about a five
billion dollar a part of our economy and
the chess events are a really new
addition to that I mean these chess
events have only been going on for in
less than a decade and the sink fell cup
is is the newest of those but there are
you know the the US Nationals the Chess
Championships for both men and women and
many other tournaments they've been
coming here and and what it's done for
our tourism industry is it's it's
broadened our reach to a very
international audience that has a
specific interest in chess of course but
finds all the great things that there
are to do in our region and with the
chess club being located and with the
with museum the hall of fame in the
museum all being located right here in
the central west end which is a hip and
and you know very trendy and highly
visited area it's really added to the
diversity of our area we hear a lot of
languages from many people who coming
from all over the world to experience
this so we love it well I've had
families accost me here from from
Georgia and from Minnesota saying that
they just came just for this even the
fact that chest is here and they wanted
their kids to see it so clearly it's
been a great attraction and we
appreciate all the work that you do
as president of explore st. Louis and
thank you to all the energy to this
great city thank you it was great to see
everybody out in front you know people
young and old just picking up games and
playing chess out on the streets and you
know that that kind of activity didn't
happen here before so well thanks to to
everybody who's working on making this a
great Jess city one last question for
you how's your chess game these days ah
yeah I'm really bad I need I need some
lessons I think there's a place you can
get some I think there is thank you so
much kitty ratcliffe of explore so you
loads the president of explore st. Louis
definitely a wonderful city to visit and
you you might get some lessons I know a
couple of people